so a florida woman was arrested for
calling 911 more than 12 000 times i
mean i guess the only thing worse than
calling the police and them not helping
you is calling the police over 12 000
times and then not helping you uh this
particular woman called over 500 times
in just one 24-hour period look i get it
you're not a fan of the police
fair but 12 000 calls is probably
excessive police officials said that her
calls accounted for 12 of incoming
traffic at that particular police
department the criminal complaint
against this woman includes a bunch of
first amendment protected activity it
says she continuously calls harasses
bilateral swears at argues with and
demands officers come arrest her then
she refuses to answer the door has in
the past given officers the middle
finger and screams at them through the
windows and while flipping off the
police is not a crime making thousands
of false 9-1-1 calls is but at least
here we have a happy outcome because
after 12 000 calls she was arrested
again just as she requested